okay [ __ ] we right through the
hardest mission we've ever done a very
difficult one I'm saying it's me very
typical are here Sam Sam you're gonna
let [ __ ] shotgun I never liked the
cannon okay
[ __ ] that
so nobody could [ __ ] is why can't
just use a bioroid walk shut the [ __ ]
this [ __ ] [ __ ] is live so mad all
done
like people say like psychobabble like
so angry all the times act like that
[ __ ] amateur our position to drop how
to strengthen your folks on the ground
I'm pretty jet kidding I mean it may be
kind of a shady now like why would a
demo but resistance on board about image
to disable a UFO that set down near one
of their camps in this area they gave us
the ship's position and it's likely to
be carrying valuable alien technology so
we're moving in to secure the site
neutralize any hostile contacts on
approach yeah
okay so I'm gonna be doing while saving
this okay
thanks for abandoning us menace 1 5 UFO
site coordinates locked in move to
secure get a neutralize all hostels
we're in concealment and huge [ __ ]
UFO you see if this is the best part for
this guy you can't really go there
hit-girl my way
okay order this vicious
this is [ __ ] disastrous that is a lot
closer and moving on target location so
this is not a snake drop one over there
this guy almost completely useless
oh [ __ ] that was the second sniper dude
what the [ __ ] am i doing
move what the [ __ ] I was thinking okay
well how far can my serenade no I said I
want to do it for no it's [ __ ]
mustache
Jony like sausage
[Music]
if I can take out this fat chippy can't
stop mess or you're fired
so you're [ __ ] fired it's still only
when I do this I might have a chance of
[ __ ] poison all them
[ __ ] I don't [ __ ] know what to do now
cook they're on the move on overwatch
okay now we're going to create an
amazing this guy [ __ ] oh that's awesome
yeah [ __ ] no we right there okay mess
that's hate these guys they're right
there just like we're here man oh [ __ ]
there holy [ __ ] this one's getting
[ __ ] up minutes one five we just
picked up an outbound signal coming from
the UFO it's some kind of distress
beacon you need to get inside that ship
and shut down the signal before they
send their whole fleet after us uh plane
this guy right here this machinist right
yeah
okay [ __ ] arms hanging up
target down should we come back right
yeah alright I guess you should [ __ ]
hide right and then aid protocol himself
just kill him I think it was what did
you expect
well the whole guys [ __ ] standing out
there male know right now who is that oh
just a dude on the ground [ __ ] there's
just a lot of guys they're gonna shoot
this base he's going to hit him no cover
oh he is so [ __ ] lucky it was cause
[ __ ]
that that's right target one more attack
one more attack [ __ ]
this guy should [ __ ] do a protocol on
snap now this [ __ ]
give them defense while other one runs
in so I got a [ __ ] a okay yeah it's
good you can probably run in now right
night-night I'm not sure who's gonna
shoot out their colleagues your heavy
cetera mess mess mess mess mess mess
mess thank God [ __ ] what's he doing
okay let me get this sure that it whoo
x-ray neutralize us I'm talking about
that means that's just what I'm talking
about Chloe go over watch this [ __ ] has
to go in for the kill
wrote to that Venice 1/5 that's the
distress beacon move in and disable it
before the aliens get a bead on the UFO
applause or an admin position what's up
[ __ ]
now maybe [ __ ] [ __ ] you never know I
love saying that I like you now right
now and there's just like [ __ ] [ __ ]
piss with him all the way I was gonna
they're gonna [ __ ] fry this guy like
I'm gonna
his body's going to shoot him again
so [ __ ] is going on here guys thought he
just walked in and got [ __ ] fried now
Kerry thank God was [ __ ] me that
weird good question mark one [ __ ] I was
[ __ ] up
he's fun and I got [ __ ] executed nice
way to go on top the UFO I guess there's
no going on top of it weird okay
can this guy [ __ ]
eating a caramel what the [ __ ] happens
his [ __ ] mustache I'm still holding
don't meet you man
oh [ __ ] adjusting aim okay whatever to
[ __ ] another one another autosave feel
like there's one that I see right before
you the guy [ __ ] ran in oh no that
was it he ran in when there are still
people outside [ __ ] okay this is the one
that guys
Nick get him one shot good to show
talking about that's [ __ ] I'm talking
about
Oh watch it didn't get this person here
all my way and then take a shot at this
guy [ __ ] this shall fail to can make
weapons MC gone engage that's priceless
let's [ __ ] yeah I didn't get it we've
been spooning at my past second that's
right
okay
welcome round
Oh
while a nap
I've got eyes on an admin position there
we go okay - one five that's the
distress beacon move in and disable it
before the aliens get a bead on the UFO
now let's talk about a bit off man guys
it's low smoke and walking through seven
this is the guy that [ __ ] is at a
protocol
because he's about to get lit up over
watch sure thing hon over watch to
happen yeah on miss miss miss miss miss
miss miss thank God okay what's the
second strike he's not going to miss now
[ __ ]
thank God [ __ ]
okay this is where [ __ ] [ __ ] is
getting real
well this extensive [ __ ] one for it
moving
[Music]
Oh see that guy right there that's right
you never know at the plate and should
be
you know just keep on [ __ ] tired on
this guy fire again I'm spending single
breath epic oh [ __ ] now wait now [ __ ] at
least you can turn it off right please
please oh yeah wait what the [ __ ]
fucking-a to shed
almost feel horny wait here's a guy has
to revising isn't he now
[ __ ] a woman's Bernadette whole fat
[ __ ] sector pod reflection rank of
alien that [ __ ] Shiite
that's heavy fire in this town I don't
know what I was at the early response
that was close
God [ __ ] man it's one five we've got
confirmation of multiple inbound
transports looks like they've locked on
to the distress beacon neutralize all
hostile reinforcements to secure the
site they got him I say met
maybe yeah
target eliminated asset located [ __ ]
real of [ __ ] we're going to go
hey Saracen has it I like fish up shitty
still not they're good okay see what I
can do though [ __ ]
mammatus
it's getting pretty tough what the [ __ ]
I thought discussions throw grenade
hostile target down I think I feel like
chef farmer still holding key yellow all
the tech news mark is that all you got
no problem plays other good at this time
[Applause]
nice target neutralized scatter go run
whoo
fire damage what is that the [ __ ] was
that
[Applause]
hostile terminated status confirmed
mission accomplished
hey Caesar I thought I'd take y'all